you talked him into it way to go mr.
Macqueen Cruz you could talk the
snowmobile into an air conditioner
you're going with me with that thing
yeah you still need my help you're
brittle like a fossil
[Music]
I don't need a trainer out here Cruz
you're old
what have you fallen this Beach and
can't get up well life's a beach and
then you drive this is beautiful
I can see why mr. sterling said you
wanted a train out here as soon as this
thing's booted up we'll get you on the
treadmill and I'll track your speed what
no the whole idea is getting my tires
dirty Real Racing I'm not driving on
that thing when I've got the sand and
the whole off Oh
okay sweetie let's do this
welcome the racer to fireball a beach
it's thought of home for today's good
right test of speed our finish line will
be the abandoned appear in the distance
all right other than quicken faster than
fast
I am spat is great self-motivation did
you come up with that yeah I did
[Music]
[Music]
good hey what was my speed I don't know
I can only track you on the treadmill no
treadmills
Oh what about Hamilton Hamilton here
who's Hamilton my electronic personal
assistant you know like on your phone
you do have a phone don't you where he
scars don't have phones cruse Hamilton
check mr. McQueen speed and reported
tracking I'll stay as close as I can
your suit will transmit your speeds to
Hamilton fine whatever let's do this
quicker the quick faster impasse I am
speak come on Luigi under your mod
[Music]
I didn't go on sans you gotta ease into
your start so your tires can grab okay
okay you do work with race cars don't
you yeah but never outside all right
let's go again I'm a brain out of rain
go again under go
[Music]
the beach ate me
all right curves pick a line on the
compacted sand got after-action you're
gonna spin out let's do this thing
[Music]
[Music]
now you're gonna take off slow to let
your tires grab yes and pick a straight
line on Harts answer you don't spin out
uh-huh all the Crabbie's I've gone
night-night mr. McQueen all right let's
go again
[Music]
[Music]
congratulations how did I do you topped
out at 198 198 that's it still slower
than storm wasted my whole day I
wouldn't say that it did feel great to
be out here doing real racing and real
racing we're on a beach all you do is go
straight how am I gonna get Bastyr if I
don't under hallo
Thunder hallo there's a dirt track there
that's what I need to race against
actual racers no to public if the press
find you they will be like many many
bugs on you I see huh guys I really need
this hey just leave it to me boss hi I'm
a master of disguise
[Music]
one reason storm and the next gens are
more efficient their ability to hold the
optimum racing line every single lap for
the multi sensation storms in a class of
his own and a big reason for that
training on the newest cutting-edge
simulators these machines create a
virtual racing experience so real racers
never even have to go outside storms
ability to hold that line is like
nothing we've ever seen or they're wrong
are you kidding me no percent lower drag
coefficient 1.2 percent higher top speed
hey Bobby who is that that's um
Jackson storm yeah he's one of the
rookies thank you
hey Jackson storm right great race today
Wow thank you mr. McQueen you have no
idea what a pleasure it is for me to
finally beat you
oh thanks wait did you say meet or beat
I think you heard me come on let's get a
picture you know what to get a ton of
pictures because champ here has been a
role model of mine for years now and I
mean a lot of years right I love this
guy
I think I touched a nerve
[Music]
it grows
oh hey mr. sterling I'd like to
introduce you to Lightning McQueen here
you're the maestro
mr. sterling did you say Lightning
McQueen was here because I don't see him
anywhere uh but he's right here do you
know to see him nope still don't see him
to view each Lightning McQueen EES
obviously an impostor it looks old and
broken-down hey with flabby tires I do
not use that quote oh yeah I see I can
use that energy from motivation right
it's all about motivation mr. McQueen
you can use anything negative as fuel to
push through to the positive but pretty
positive ever since I was a rookie I am
so excited that I get to train you I
grew up watching you on TV huh
is that right these young guys are great
and all but I like a challenge
not that much all right I call you my
senior project
you are about to become the biggest
brand in racing movie deals infomercial
product endorsements fit ciao you think
you're famous now will be rich beyond
belief
mr. sterling what is this about your
legacy every time you lose you damage
yourself I'm sorry your racing days are
coming to an end
we can only hope that this race today
wasn't his last I decide when I'm done
how you feeling I can't go out on the
track and do the same old thing it won't
work it's futile to resist change man
you know what I do what I don't know I
got nothing
I am so excited to train you I like a
challenge
ha ha I call you my senior project
dad the beach ate me Jackson storm set a
new record today when he pulled off the
fastest left ever recorded
hi everybody the latest record storm
inside even any thoughts on a queen
this is my last chance Cruz last if I
lose I never get to do this again don't
fear failure be afraid of not having the
chance you have the chance
ace to watch you on TV flying through
the air you seemed so fearless
it was shiny wood that felt like
you'll never be as fast distorted but
you can be smarter than him
the racing is the reward at the stop
winning our ninety five point two
percent
way
you
you